[Music]  you get in trouble with your wife a lot  do you get in trouble with your wife  often well that's I'm constantly in  trouble she doesn't well here's here's  an example the other day she she said I  would never do this and she stipulated  she was she made sure she was adamant  listen I would never do it but if I ever  agreed to a threesome which one of my  friends would you choose yeah yeah yeah  you should guess for that yeah that's a  dangerous fellow yeah you don't answer  that yeah just like you start a fire in  your house or something here's the thing  if you're stupid enough to answer  because I did let me just a little one  warning make sure you understand the  question don't name two of her friends  [Laughter]  get dead were so dead